what's up everybody dj here kevin hart
you're about to play the bff game on the
one and only buzzfeed here we go all
right um i got a feeling that i just
want to say that i know so much about
you i don't have a feeling i know you
know i'm invested buddy i've been for a
long time
[Music]
one easy one their birthday it's easy
for me february 16th wow that's not my
birthday yeah no man no may 2nd really
yeah yeah no i've told you that for
years because you give me gifts on my
birthday you call me happy birthday to
you get out of here yeah no not february
16th maybe a second little rest it's
okay it's the first one yes but i know
you yeah april 27th no july 6th july 6th
yeah when was that it's always been like
that since i was born
yeah wow july oh god all right their
middle name
easy uh come on croatia no croatia yes
no man the wayne croatia johnson no not
at all that's not even close i thought
you didn't your mother have a story
about croatia and she said that she
would love to go to croatia no but it
wasn't like that's my middle name get
out of here okay douglas man dwayne
douglas douglas yeah that's [ __ ]
stupid wow really we've talked about
this wow
okay jesus christ what's your middle
name darnell yes well that [ __ ] sucks
you got two d's two d's in a row kevin
darnell heart double dick doesn't know
kevin darnell heart wayne doesn't gonna
[ __ ] pay to see that nathan ugh you
can't sell a ticket with that oh they're
pet peeve got it no this one ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding
what is that smell in his balls right
here that's my pet pee yeah you do it
all the time we're all set i'll catch
you in the corner no but it's not a pet
peeve i enjoy doing that
i know where your pet peeve is yeah i
know you know kyle i know when the
streaming doesn't go well when you're
watching uh pornhub yeah well that's
your pet peeve well that's good
he knows me we're in bad locations he
knows me oh bad timing oh wow first time
we met this one i do know what it is
wrestlemania with hulk hogan hulk hogan
was going up against uh ric flair and i
saw you front row i was young you
weren't i mean a hungry wrestler you
know i'm a kid you're a lot older than
me and i was like man i just want to
tell you i love you dude one day we're
going to work together you was like
all right wow yeah me and you i don't
remember that but when we did meet i
remember where it was it was a comedy
club in philly it was 2 a.m and you were
on stage you remember that and i was
like you [ __ ] suck and you're like
hey hey who is a come on i can't see you
because of the light get the off stage
it's insane it's part of the winter i
never knew this remember that yeah
i remember it i just didn't know that
was me that was me yes
oh the childhood celebrity crush oh
oh
man childhood let me think you told me
so much i did you told me so many no i
just i didn't tell you so i'm gonna go
with willis from different strokes
he was man that was my childhood crush
yeah he used to say i wish he would i
would no no don't don't reveal that
oh really oh really is that what we're
looking for yours was yours was mr
drummond from different strokes remember
that
[Music]
i used to be god i wish he would
touch my ear like that
remember that you used to tell me that
yeah yeah what your favorite curse word
oh i know
that
favorite curse word jesus i don't know
man if i had to guess see i know yours
already i think i don't know
i'm going to go with i'm going to go
damn it
it's so big everybody expects you to say
the big stuff the hard ones but you're
like damn it
damn it that was when i was young though
yeah damn it what do you think mine's
yours is uh this should be easy come on
man oh stink pickle no that's not the
cuss word that was that you oh stink
pickle and used to be pissed remember
that like what's a sting pickle you're
like here i'll show you i'm like no
kevin okay this one no let's be serious
nickname for your wife i'm gonna say
you're everything that's awesome
yes that is and i remember you said the
most beautiful woman in the world that's
right rule number one and best friends
always make the wives happy you don't
play around here buddy no
no oh god your favorite movie oh
i know yours god all right i'm gonna go
with you because i know you yes i'm
gonna say your favorite movie mm-hmm
sleepless in seattle wow yeah cause you
like love story i do man you're a fan of
tom hanks sleepless in seattle by the
way yeah you love love stories too yeah
yours is two girls and one cup well
that's not a
[Music]
that's i don't think that's
a different kind of story buddy but all
right you call me remember you're like
hey look it up yeah my mother looking up
i just said look at this this thing i
never wanted to all right the name of
your dogs easy very very easy come on
now jason stay them no yeah no close so
yeah jason statham no no no no no no no
no jay steve oh no jay state come on j
steve no no no no no hobs man
see it was kind of close
you see how i messed it up i see okay
the names of your dogs is um you know
this i know you know this roxy yep
uh-huh come on now and coochie no what
no i don't know
[Laughter]
all right okay
wow i'll tell you what i checked i got
them all
that didn't check check it in your box
but i had to have won that one i
basically got two of mine right and you
because you i got it all right i got
them all right so i got them all right
as you can see i know my bff there's a
goal post that's exactly what it's about
knowing your bff right thank you
buzzfeed for bringing us closer together
we love you buzzfeed your birthday is
really not in february no man why we've
been double celebrating black history
month
i've been throwing you two parties this
whole time no i haven't said anything
yeah i thought it was
buzzfeed here we go dc league of super
pets dc league of super pets myself and
kevin well we got a lot there's a lot of
people a lot of people piano reeves yeah
i go down the list but we don't have
that type of time denzel yes there's no
well no one no enjoy
[Laughter]
[Music]
you